[Music]
starting off this hour is david and
charlotte hi david welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave so great to talk to you um
appreciate you taking my call sure
so
i'm 53 and me and my wife have been
following your philosophy for many years
we are through all the baby steps we
have our house paid off just as about
two years ago
and we actually have another house a
rental house that's totally paid for
um
great so we also yeah it's great we
are very blessed and i have a great
business that i love
um here's my question um
you know we have
iras and roth iras
you know i say we've been following your
philosophy but the only thing
that i can't seem to do
is keep money
in the stock market i have made many
mistakes pulling it out putting it back
in
um
and you know we've it's cost us a lot of
money
if i would have just kept it in there we
would have been you know we would have
had quite a bit more in our iras
now my question is like do i really you
know mentally it's just a problem for me
to keep it in there it's been
i want to watch it every day
multiple times looking at it
question is do i really need to have
money in the stock market at this point
no i mean you could just buy real estate
if you want to do that and do whatever
you want to do there's no there's no uh
mandate that you do this
but
i would challenge you i would challenge
you david that i think what you do need
to do
is you do need to learn how to um
analyze and assess and learn about an
investment
and then may be able to make a choice to
do that investment or not do that
investment
okay so you bought this rental property
right
yes
do you fret about it
no why we don't
because
it's not something that can go up and
down every day yes it is
well you're right um
i guess it's just it's just different
for me it's a tangible thing i can see
it
um i get a rent check every month
um
but you also said a minute ago you also
said a minute ago that if you'd left the
money in the market you would have a lot
more now
that's true okay
so here's the thing
it's always interesting to me the the
biggest difference in real estate
uh
in actual fact is that it is tangible
that you can walk over there and touch
the bricks and mortar and you know see
if there's weeds in the yard or whatever
right that kind of thing
um and that does give us an emotional
comfort that is a reasonable
observation okay
but what real estate does not do that's
different than stock is there is zero
guarantees
the only reason that we become
emotionally comfortable with real estate
is because we are more intimately
familiar
with its history with its track record
because we grew up with it we grew up in
that neighborhood we've been around that
neighborhood 20 years whatever and you
just kind of go well houses in that
neighborhood go up and even if there was
a bump in the road and went down a
little bit i'm not going to panic
because generally houses in that
neighborhood have been are worth a lot
more than they were 20 years ago and i'm
just even though that might have been a
weekly or a monthly thing or even a
annual thing where it was a little soft
or a little bad
no need to panic because i'm good with
the long-term track record right
i would challenge you that
you should be able to do the same thing
with the stock market
now if you don't want to i'm not going
to be mad at you but this is an
intellectual exercise in other words
learning something new that you don't
know today because if you could
internalize
the historical data on the stock market
by sitting with a smart vista pro and
learning and looking at this i've got
one mutual fund that's 80 something
years old it's only had like 10 or 15
down years out of 80 years it's got a
12.2 average annual return for 80 years
that's more safe than your rental house
right statistically mathematically
right but you got to get that down in
your heart
so you quit looking at the freaking
charts every day
i don't look at my mutual funds any more
often than i look at my real estate
so i'm not i'm not trying to say you're
stupid for not doing this if you can't
get comfortable stop doing it okay but i
think as a part of your personal growth
plan
you
demanding of yourself that you learn
something new
would be you just need to study this
market a little bit this market the
stock market thing a little bit more so
if you want to pull it out and say i'm
not going in for three more years but i
am gonna meet with my
smartvista pro
who has the heart of a teacher and i'm
gonna get comfortable because of
knowledge
uh my people perish for lack of
knowledge the bible says
so it's just knowledge gives you
calmness yeah on top of the perspective
of looking back at the stock market for
40 years and going oh the s p 500 some
serious appreciation there with just a
few dips i feel good about this over the
long term so we talk about how the only
people that get hurt on the roller
coaster are the ones who jump off early
and you jumped off early a whole bunch
of times and that hurt and you don't
want to go back on that roller coaster
but like dave's saying if you meet with
a smart investor pro and they outline
all this for you you're going gonna go
okay i feel good about getting that roth
ira back up and going investing in good
growth stock mutual funds diversified
across four types we're not talking
about single stocks that are super
volatile i agree don't do that but if
you're talking about the stock market in
general
it's a safe bet over the long term yeah
so you know here's the thing david if
you are 100 gonna jump in and out of it
stop doing it
because you're going to lose money
okay
just stop stop and go on and do
something else
you know and go buy some real estate and
there but i i just when i bump into
something like that there's two kinds of
fear that we all have me included
i have fear
of things that i should be afraid of i
don't need to touch a hot stove i don't
need to stand in the middle of the
interstate with 18 wheelers coming by
okay that's a that's a good fear it
saves your life
because the data
around that fear is
that you know if you're not afraid
you're gonna get killed okay or burned
or whatever right so but the other kind
of fear is false evidence appearing real
f-e-a-r okay
and that is i just don't know yet it's
like the first time i i'll never forget
i've told this story on the air 100
times my dad gives me the keys to the
car that was dumber than a rock i was 12
years old so i moved the car around back
well it was a long time ago we gravel
driveway so i got in the car 12 years
old started the car
and stepped on the accelerator all the
way the floor oh boy i just about dug a
ditch in the driveway with those back
tires spinning on that gravel driveway
because i mean i did what i was doing
and you know when you first learn to
drive you're freaking out because you
don't know what you're doing
but now you drive with your knees and
people put on their makeup and eat and
do calculations and check their twitter
account while they're driving dave i
think you still drive like that 12 year
old you're burning rubber i've seen you